what the hell happened see everyone with
that question but I actually I know what
happened and I'll probably talk about it
I don't usually talk about
behind-the-scenes chicanery that's an
old-timey word uh um whenever I discuss
TV movies whatever but in this case it
feels really relevant to where American
Gods went in its second season and it it
went south in what was possibly the
worst way for a show like this it got
dull because whatever you think about
the first season it was not dull this
time look here's the thing
part of me wants to say that if I had
not seen season one if this had been
season one effectively that I will
probably like I wouldn't love it the way
I love season one but I probably like it
decently but this suffers by the
comparison and that may even be true but
it's a necessary comparison it's a
direct continuation of the exact same
show like how can you not compare so
it's not like oh you need to look at it
in a vacuum
it doesn't exist in a vacuum so that
doesn't work even though that's like the
kindest thing I can say to it and it's
not even like it goes massively off the
rails in a way that's interesting to
talk about like I could talk all day
about how Game of Thrones or Dexter went
off the rails in their last season I'd
have plenty to talk about there I don't
feel like I have as much to talk about
here
I get it which is probably why I'll end
up talking about some of the behind the
scenes stuff actually let's get that out
of the way so the showrunners for the
first season
did not do the show running for the
second season it was done by somebody
else who actually was fired before the
season started shooting
he wrote the scripts and then was fired
and they then moved to him with those
scripts I think they brought in somebody
like polished them up and then they shot
that they had like an interim showrunner
and now for season three which is
supposed to air later this year it was a
completely different showrunner so
officially the show runners for the
first season were never actually fired
nor did they quit they just didn't show
run the second season which if I were to
guess in my semi educated way I would
say most likely the reason that they
were not brought back was budgetary that
first season went over budget by
millions and as acclaimed as it was no
network like something that goes over
budget when they decided how much they
want to pay for something they expect
that thing to be a hit for what they
paid for it so when you spend more than
they agreed to spend and you end up with
a hit you go oh yeah we spent too much
but we we got a hit the thinking from
the personal ders is well you were
always supposed to make a hit but you
were supposed to make a hit for what we
agreed to pay so that's if I were to
guess that that was the main reason why
they were not brought back I think it
was concerned that their sensibilities
in terms of both writing and production
would put everything over budget again
and it might have but you can tell the
they are a lot more conservative with
the use of special effects and many of
them are way less inventive some of them
are still neat but like like right off
the bat first episode
they they have the gin and he takes his
sunglasses off and they don't even show
the fire like it's like two frames and
then it's from behind it like you have
the sound of the fire from the eyes that
I actually show it because then they'd
have to pay for the effect I cost money
so you can you can write from episode
one you can see where things have been
trimmed but the effects ultimately
aren't the biggest issue they are a
little bit of an issue because the
vibrancy and and the effects of your
work was a big part of the feeling the
identity of the first season but there
is still some of that here it's not as
much it's not as pervasive but what's
here is still fairly solid as far as
that stuff goes so it's the writing
that's the problem and for me to explain
this I might have to spoil some of the
book I'll give you a heads up before I
before I do that though so the main
thing is that this season lacks a clear
sense of focus and a clear sense of
purpose the first season was all of
these characters and all of these
threads drawing together you had shadow
with mr. Wednesday who he was learning
about you have mr. Wednesday collecting
these old gods they were all gonna go
and meet up together and it culminated
like right before that meeting was going
to happen so we basically built to the
meeting this season opens with that
meeting and then character split apart
again we spent the entire season pulling
everybody together and now they've just
scattered to the winds again as Matt
Sweeney and Laura go off on on their own
again for a while and then Laura's with
Wednesday for a little bit and shadows
left back at the funeral parlor for a
while and mr. world is doing his own
thing which if they're going to preserve
some of the things about mr. world from
the book that is making less and less
and less sense but again that'll tie
into
spoiler stuff so I'll come back to that
but then they've got this entire subplot
with media and now it's new media and
then they give tech boy like more
background which I'm not sure why and we
get an entire new origin format suite
which isn't uninteresting but I actually
liked what we find what we found out
about him and season one better and that
felt like enough that for us to get um
oh and addressing the media thing they
also lost some actors it again it's not
100% clear why you know whether it was
dissatisfaction with the scripts weather
was just availability because the this
thing took so long to get off the ground
or a combination so Kristin Chenoweth
who is Easter at the end of the first
season she's not back her absence is
taking care of in a very hastily said
line that like makes no sense but fine
and then media played by Gillian
Anderson now media they couldn't get rid
of oh well they could have but they
decided they weren't going to they we're
gonna keep media around so instead we
have the rebirth of new media now here's
what I'll say about this if they were
going to keep the character around going
in a vastly different direction from
Gillian Anderson's media and leaning
into different kinds of media more
up-to-date types of media and a
completely different personality was
probably the best thing that they could
do under the circumstances because if
you try and get someone to come back and
recreate Gillian Anderson it's it's not
gonna work
so better to lean the other way and just
be like no we're not even gonna try and
do that here's this new thing and new
media is functional she works decently I
think part of the problem is attitude
and tone and line delivery she's a
little bit too close to tech boy or at
least what tech boy was in season one
they messed with him a little bit in a
way that was like they they made him
flattered he wasn't as as bouncy as he
was before he didn't have the same kind
of Enter
I think person because they gave all the
high energy to new media instead but
again if they couldn't get Gillian
Anderson I think they handled that about
as well as they could but overall just
this whole season feels like stalling it
feels like wheel spinning because like I
said first season everything was coming
together and it was building towards a
battle and in this season it's building
towards a battle end of the season we
are not a vastly different place from
when the season started so you know
spoilers for season two if you haven't
seen the whole thing yet so like shadow
isn't with Wednesday anymore
and sweeties dead but what else has
changed not a lot
mr. worlds thing is whatever his plan is
is still cooking at roughly the same
pace Wednesday had a spear and now he
doesn't so he's back where he started as
far as that goes
Laura's still dead it's so little
changes from the start of the season to
where it ends and the climax was very
strange to me the whole thing with like
the police and everything I think maybe
it's because we've been dealing with
gods that like the big oh god what's
gonna happen it was just the cops
showing up I mean the way they got
brought down in the use of new media
that was pretty good but like really so
I to get into my other complaints and
this all ties into it the fact that it
is wheel spinning because they are
stalling assuming they even keep it they
are stalling on part of the story and
you can and it feels like they're
stalling
Oh before I get to that the one other
thing I'll say performances are all good
the material they're working with isn't
as great
but the performance is also good though
for me the highlight this time um and he
was a highlight last time but last time
the complete MVP who walked away with
the entire show was Wednesday was ian
mcshane now even me she's so good in
this one but for me walking away with
the whole thing was Orlando Jones as mr.
Nancy Anansi he was so good and he was
so good last time but he was even better
this time I loved virtually everything
about this character I loved his
attitude I loved his anger I loved that
he does not give a damn what anybody
else thinks about what he has to say
I like that he shifts his accent as he
talks and he'll get angrier and it'll
get more guttural I love all of that and
he is apparently not in season 3 I'll
touch on this really quick because I
already opened the door to back you know
behind the scenes stuff there's
conflicting reasons as to why Orlando
Jones is not in season 3 his version was
that he had a conversation with a new
showrunner who basically told him that
well he basically said he was
uncomfortable with an ante as a
character something to the effect of
this this angry character is not what
black America needs as an example I'm
paraphrasing someone who was giving only
their side of the story so don't take
that for what was actually said and that
struck me as a little bit mmm that felt
a little bit too clean-cut for me to buy
completely that felt like one side of
the story we're missing the other now
the other side of the story you know the
folks who actually did not bring back
Orlando Jones did give their side of the
story but for reasons I'll explain in a
minute I'm actually more inclined to
believe Orlando Jones under the
circumstances or at least believe the
truth leans more in his direction the
word from stars was that he wasn't fired
his contract wasn't renewed because
Anansi does not appear in the sections
of the book they're planning to adapt
for the third season now the reason I
call absolute BS on that is they have
diverged so far
from the book sent this book singular
there there is kind of another one
because there's a Nancy boys Medusa
spin-off but they're not pulling from
the material from that this thing is
diverged so much from the book that they
can't hide behind that and an odyssey
was a pretty big part of this one so to
just have him vanishing oh well buddy's
not in these parts of the book yeah
neither was mad Sweeney he dies really
quick in that book you kept him around
for freaking ever don't act like you're
you're not bringing back because of
fidelity of the books that bad I don't
believe at all does that mean I believe
100 percent Orlando Jones's story no but
under the circumstances that has a more
of a ring of truth than the other one so
wherever the truth lies I think it leans
a little bit more towards his end of
things but okay I need to talk bucks
spoilers to get into my ladder and
complaints as to part of why this has
become such a mess or at least become so
dull a mess would be more interesting
so that's your warning spoilers for the
book which means potential spoilers for
later seasons of this show
alright so the thing is the show is a
little bit in a little bit of an
unenviable position because they have
such a fantastic mr. Wednesday but
Wednesday spends a very large portion of
the book dead he actually doesn't
doesn't survive all that I mean he
survives longer than Matt Sweeney does
but he's dead for a really big chunk of
the book but I can see why having Ian
McShane they want to keep him around for
as long as possible but keeping him
around means that you are delaying the
big turning point and the thing that so
much stuff is meant to pivot on you're
just delaying that which is why the
second season feels like it's nothing
but stalling because really when it
opened and they had Cloris leachman's
character killed it should have opened
with Wednesday
being killed but it didn't and as a
result we're just running on a hamster
wheel for pretty much the whole season
because the plot can't move forward
until he dies that's assuming they're
gonna preserve the plot at all which
they better if they didn't bring back
Orlando Jones because they're sticking
to the plot here's the other thing and I
alluded to this if they're sticking to
the book plot the mr. world makes no
sense at all because again spoilers like
this is the big one this is the big one
okay so in the book mr. world isn't real
mr. world is an act it's low-key
the entire thing is a con so all of this
Wednesday gathering everybody up world
having Wednesday killed that galvanizing
the old gods against the new God so it
can actually culminate in the battle the
point of that battle is that that battle
is is in tribute to Wednesday to Odin so
that he will he will be reborn and he
will be more powerful than ever the
entire thing's a kind if they're gonna
keep that twist then they're mr. world
makes absolutely no sense because he's
already missed the opportunity to kill
Wednesday which is supposed to be the
thing that the entire con pivots on and
his actions instead now make no sense
it's like oh I'm preparing and preparing
preparing for what it's all fake what
are you preparing it's ah and the thing
you need to do to sell your con you had
the opportunity to do it and you didn't
you've had multiple opportunities to do
it and you didn't
so they've either got to change that or
they have really shot themselves in the
foot after this season because it make
it makes absolutely no sense now huh oh
and they did the reveal of shadow being
Wednesday's kid which I didn't love in
the book either I mean
makes some degree of sense it's
functional I just whatever so yeah
that's American god season 2 I don't
know when I'll get around to season 3 I
don't even know when it's supposed to
air I know it's supposed to be this year
season 1 was so good it was so good and
it was in rapture and you know what else
season 2 feels like gratuitous like
season 1 had a lot of nudity and sex in
it but it didn't feel as gratuitous it
didn't feel as exploitative as it does
here like we just characters just go to
a strip club why so he can show tits
that's why and no I say this like they
even have a legitimate burlesque number
which I appreciate as a pro less
performer cool but like there's also all
these sex scenes and the whole thing
with Baron Samedi and like that God that
was that was a complete narrative
cul-de-sac that went nowhere
again wheel spinning stalling and I'm
stalling now I don't know why I'll wrap
up now I can God season 2 what you think
about it whatever your thoughts are
drops let me down Lee comes let's talk
about all these you'll stuff to do like
subscribe share this around check out my
patreon etc etc etc but you do not have
to pray and pay tribute to me because at
the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]